can you name five television shows where
the show's headliner is your gender and
ethnicity okay like I said the secret
life for American teen that's one of
them another one would probably be like
this is tough there's not a lot of
performance maybe like the Mindy project
it's more open to like different
ethnicities another one would probably
be well five
hold on about that oh gosh
actually cannot
or at least I wouldn't well because all
of the TV series i watch arm into
they're very white I would say scandal
but that's more black then you know like
mixed that's kind of it oh gosh that's
terrifying but no I can't really think
of anything
probably some Disney Channel shows I
don't I don't know all of them but just
some of them are really open to because
I know one show has an Indian boy now so
I mean like they're kind of open now too
I guess
agent kind of Indian types of roles
that's like a name so far of it yeah
well this specific season has been a
really interesting season because in the
asian-american or we've really been
celebrating the the emergence of a lot
of really really wonderful performers
and and and some of them are friends of
mine
you know selfie is out I think it's on
ABC as John Cho and he's playing a
romantic lead and I think that's great
it's too bad that it's taken this long
for something like that to happen but he
certainly earned you know his right to
be you know where he is and I think it's
great
gang-related as another show that I
think just recently got canceled
unfortunately but some Kang as a
wonderful actor and he's one of these
series regulars in that as well so
there's been several you know a friend
of mine a very dear friend of mine just
got cast as a love interest in the
Vampire Diaries
Emily Chang and so there it's slowly
starting to happen and
fresh-off-the-boat
is basically a new show that's out I
think it's CBS or ABC I can't remember
but it's based on a really really
popular best-selling novel about the
Taiwanese American experience and and it
sort of revolves around this young kid
growing up with Taiwanese American
parents and so it's about that kind of
culture shock of dealing with the
parents you know experience as as sort
of
immigrants in this country raising a
family building businesses and then him
growing up as an American but so there
is quite a lot that's out right now in
terms of relatively speaking but I'm
sure in terms of percentage it's still
you know really really not not big
enough
you